The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high-quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
GEORGE VERGHESE:
OK, let's continue.
So we're going to
continue with linear codes
and talk today about
error correction.
So let me just remind you,
we're thinking of linear codes
very concretely
as being generated
through a process like this.
We put this up on the
board several times.
You've got the
data bits and then
the parity bits being generated
by the data bits multiplying
into a so-called
generator matrix.
You've seen this in lecture
on recitation as well.
And we've considered different
ways to think of this matrix.
One way is to think of it as
made up of a bunch of rows,
and what you're doing is
taking linear combinations
of these rows to
generate a code word.
So the dimensions here--
this is going to be n.
So when you take a linear
combination of these,
you're generating a
word that's n bits long.
But the underlying
degrees of freedom only
correspond to k bits,
because you're just
doing a weighted
combination of k of these.
OK?
Now, we talk of these as
though they're vectors,
you're combining them, take the
linear combinations, and so on.
And I just wanted to
say a word about in what
sense this is a vector.
So this is an array of n bits.
So we're talking
about something--
I'll call it v, let's say--
which is an array of n bits.
And the question is, in
what sense is that a vector?
In what sense does it
live in a vector space?
So when we say vector
space, we're usually
thinking of arrays of n elements
with real numbers in them,
and the kind that you
use in physics, where
you take linear combinations
of them with real numbers
and you get new vectors.
This is the same kind
of thing, except it's
working over not the real
field, but as we've seen, gf2.
So this is a vector
space over gf2.
It's a funny vector
space, again,
because it has a finite
number of elements.
The vectors that we're
used to thinking of--
Euclidean vector space has
an infinity of elements,
because you can have an
array of n components,
but each component could
be any real number.
So any point in 3D space
would be a vector in r3.
So this is a vector
space over gf2,
and it only has a finite
number of components--
only has 2 to the
n possible vectors.
It's a finite set of vectors,
so it's strange that way too.
So in what sense is
that a vector space?
Well, it turns out that
they're pretty abstract things
that you can refer to
as vectors, provided
they satisfy certain axioms.
So what you want
to be able to do
is define a sum
of these objects.
You need to have
a set of scanners
and define a scalar times
vector multiplication.
And then you need a
0 vector, a vector
that, when you add
to another vector,
gives you the same
vector back again.
You need certain
distributivity properties.
So if you take a scalar
times the sum of two vectors,
you get things like that.
So you can list a bunch
of these properties.
I'm not trying to teach
you are the axioms are
that define the vector space.
But there's a set of
axioms, and you'll
recognize very quickly that
Euclidean space satisfies
those axioms.
But the point is there
are other objects that
satisfy the same axioms, and you
can work with them as vectors--
so notions of independence
of vectors, a basis in terms
of which you write
other vectors--
all of these.
Now, I'm not assuming you've
done a linear algebra course.
I'm assuming you've
picked up some
of this in the course of
doing physics, and so on.
I'm just trying to
talk intuitively here.
One thing we don't have here is
a notion of an inner product,
or a dot product,
or a scalar product.
So if you had two n component
vectors in Euclidean space--
you're probably used
to this from physics--
you'll take inner products
defined in this fashion.
Well, we can certainly do
this kind of computation
with the elements
of a vector here,
but the resulting object
doesn't have the properties
of an inner product.
For instance, you can take the--
if you take the inner product
of two non-zero vectors in real
vector space, you'll never get--
well, you can get
the inner product
to be 0 under very
special conditions.
There's a notion
of orthogonality.
It turns out that
doesn't actually
work quite the same way
here over this space.
So what do we do have is
we set aside orthogonality.
We'll talk about linear
combinations of vectors.
We'll talk about a
set of basis vectors.
So a set of basis vectors
would be a set of vectors
that you can take linear
combinations of to get
other vectors in the space--
and a minimal such set.
So we'll be using a bit of
the language of vector spaces.
You might have some
notions of that
might come from what
you've done with physics.
And that's all really
that we want to depend on.
All right, so back to
this-- what we have
is these arrays of n bits.
We think of them as
vectors in some space.
The dimension of the space
is the number of vectors
that you need in order
to generate other vectors
by linear combination.
So the question is, can
I generate some vector
by taking alpha 1 v1 plus
alpha 2 v2 plus alpha 3 v3?
So I'd like to be able to
generate a vector in the space
by taking a linear
combination of other vectors.
So if you ask for what's the
minimum number of such vectors
you need here in order
to be able to generate
any vector by taking a
linear combination, that's
the dimension of the space.
So in that sense, it turns
out that these anaerobes
live in an n-dimensional space.
But they don't span all
of n-dimensional space,
because you're just--
you've just got k of them here.
It turns out that
what you get by taking
linear combinations of these
is a k-dimensional subspace
of an n-dimensional space.
So in some sense,
when you define
a code, what you're
doing is you're saying,
I have this n dimensional space
that my words can live in,
but I'm going to restrict
myself to words that
live in a k-dimensional subspace
so that, if a vector pops out
of that subspace, I recognize
it as being an error.
So that's the general idea.
All of this can be
done more carefully
using the notion
of vector spaces.
I just wanted to give
you a rough idea of that.
This is one way
of thinking over.
Here was another way of thinking
of it, which was column-wise.
We think of the generator
matrix as being made up
of a bunch of columns.
And that's useful
when you want to think
about how a parity
bit is defined
in terms of the data bits.
So here's what you see when
you think of this column-wise.
So let's take p1 here.
Actually, let me
specialize this further.
We've already said that, because
of the form in which we set up
our code words, this is in
what's called systematic form.
We've got the data
bits sitting there,
and then we add in
the parity bits.
Because of that, we've said that
there's an identity matrix here
all the way down as 1's.
And then we've got
some other matrix here,
which is something
we'll denote by A.
OK, so when we do this
multiplication in the first k
positions, we just
pick up d1 to dk.
In the next position over,
I get the expression for p1.
So p1 is going to be d1
times the first entry there
plus d2 times the
second entry, and so on.
So here's what I get.
Let me call this A11
in that first row.
Here's A21, all
the way up to Ak1.
So these are just numbering the
entries down that first row.
So I'm taking a
combination like that,
a linear combination
of the data bits
to get that first parity bit.
So the j-th parity bit
is found by going over
to the j-th column.
The entries here are A1j
all the way up to Akj.
So the way matrix
multiplication works--
if I'm looking for
the j-th entry--
the j-th parity bit here, I
take this and do the dot product
kind of expression with the j-th
column, so this is what I get.
So this is a typical
parity relation.
And it goes the other way too.
If you had this expression,
and not the matrix,
you can just take those numbers
and translate them back in.
And these numbers are
just 0, 1 in our--
in the case of a binary field
that we're working over.
That is just 0, 1.
So you either have the data
bit there or you don't.
All additions or modulo
2 additions, of course.
Actually, let me call
this the parity--
it's the parity definition.
I may have had another
term for it in my slides.
Let's see here--
this parity equation.
It just defines
the parity better.
Here's what I think of
as a parity relation.
What is this sum?
What does that sum
work out to be?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
GEORGE VERGHESE: Sorry?
GEORGE VERGHESE: 0--
because I'm adding
pj to itself, and then gf2.
That gives me 0.
And this is what I think
of as a parity relation.
So a parity equation
defines my parity bits,
but I get immediately from that
a parody relation that relates
my parity bit to my data bits.
Turns out this is
important for the way
we're going to talk
about our correction.
OK, so let me step
off the dime here.
And this is a
particular example.
I just wanted to set
up the general notation
before we got back to this.
We've looked at this before--
9, 4, 4 rectangular code.
So what might that be?
How many data bits?
9, 4, 4--
4 data bits, right?
So how would I get in 9, 4, 4?
I'd have D1, D2, D3, D4.
And then, depending on how I
number this, P1, P2, P3, P4,
P5 would be one
way to number it.
I don't know if that
corresponds to what's up here.
Can we check?
So what's P1?
P1 is going to be D1 times 1
plus D2 times 1, and that's it.
So it's d1 plus D2.
So P1 is indeed that
element there on the board.
And so you can check
each of these entries.
Let's see.
P5-- that's the
last entry up there.
That's going to be this
row inner producted or dot
producted with all
the sequence of 1's
there, so it's going to be D1
plus D2 plus D3 plus D4, which
is indeed how that overall
parity bit is defined.
So again, you see in
the generator matrix,
you have the identity
matrix there,
and then you have this matrix
that we're referring to as A.
Now, the notation is
a little bit different
reading chapters 5
and 6, by the way.
I've tried to stick with the
notation I had in lecture
last time in the chapter
5 notation, which
uses capital D for the
data bit vector and capital
C for the code word.
So you'll see slightly
different notation in chapter 6,
but I think you'll
navigate fine.
One other term here--
we say that these code words
live in the row space of G. So
the space that we generate,
the space of vectors,
the subspace of the big
space that we generate
by taking linear
combinations of these rows
is referred to as
the row space of G.
So we define the
code by defining
a G. If the code's going
to be in systematic form,
we have the identity here,
and then some matrix.
This is all for linear codes.
And then the code words live in
the row space of this matrix.
In other words, they're obtained
by taking linear combinations
of the rows.
Here's what I already
have on the board.
And it's just to say that the
matrix A that's sitting out
here--
this piece-- is
obtained directly
from the parity relations.
OK, so let's think about this.
Can two columns of the
matrix A be the same?
What happens if two
columns of A are the same?
Let's say these two columns
are identical to each other.
What is that telling us
about the code that we have?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
GEORGE VERGHESE: Yeah.
And so basically, one
of those parity bits
is not buying you
anything, right?
Yeah.
OK, so if you did discover
two columns two columns were
identical, then one
of those parity bits
is not checking a different
linear combination--
checking the same
linear combination,
and so it's not
buying you anything.
What about two rows?
Can two rows of the
matrix be identical?
So let's actually think of them.
Erase that-- can I have two
identical rows here in A?
And if I did, what
would it mean?
OK, let's say I have
two identical rows.
What does it mean?
What does it signify?
Someone?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
GEORGE VERGHESE:
Could you speak up?
Sorry.
My hearing's not good.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
GEORGE VERGHESE: So
there'll be two data
bits that are entering the same
way in every parity relation.
If two rows are the
same here, then there
are two data bits
here that are entering
every parity relationship in
exactly the same combination.
And so you're not going
to be able to distinguish
between an error that happens
in one of them and the--
and an error that
happens in another one.
So this is a problem.
All right, so there are
certain conditions at the A
he has to satisfy.
All right, here's
another important matrix.
You may have already
seen it in reading.
You may not have seen
it yet in recitation.
And it's a matrix
that we call H.
And let's just think
about what it's doing.
What I'm trying
to do is basically
summarize this set of
equations, the parity
relations in matrix form.
So let's take a parity
relation that we
had in this particular case.
In fact, let's go back
to a specific one.
Let's take the first
parity relationship
that we had over there.
We said that P1 for this
code was D1 plus D2, right?
That's the equation
for the parity.
The parity relationship is this.
How would I express
that in matrix form,
as part of a matrix equation?
Well, that's what we're
starting to assemble here.
So let me show you what that is.
Let's look at the
top row out here.
What's the top row telling us?
It says 1 times D1 plus 1 times
D2 plus 1 times P1 equals 0.
That's all that enters.
So that first row is capturing
the first parity relationship.
And you can go down here.
Go to the second row.
This is saying D3 plus
D4 plus P2 is equal to 0.
That's indeed the
parity relationship
associated with the second
row in the rectangular code.
So all that this is doing
is listing all the parity
relationships.
So how many of
these do you have?
Well, you have as
many relationships
as you have parity bits.
So this is n minus
k times n matrix,
and it's just listing
the parity relations.
We call this matrix
H, and interestingly--
let's see-- there's an
identity matrix sitting here,
and the reason is that
each of these equations
involves only one parity bit.
There's only a single PI
that's involved in each parity
relation, and so there
should be only one
of these columns
picked as a 1 when
you get to this segment that
multiplies the parity bits.
So there's an identity
matrix sitting there,
and then there's
the rest of it here.
So here's the identity matrix
and here's the rest of it.
And not surprisingly,
the rest of it--
well, it comes from the
same set of coefficients,
and so it relates
to the A matrix.
And if you look at
it carefully, it
turns out, well, it is the A
matrix, but turned on its side.
A superscript T
means A transposed--
IE, rows become columns.
We're taking the a
matrix, and in some sense,
turning it on its side.
So that makes sense, because
what defined the first parity
relationship?
Well, we found it in the
columns of A here before.
That's what defined the
parity relationships.
And now we're writing
it out in this row form,
so you've got to
transpose things.
You've got to take what was a
column in A and make it a row.
So what you're seeing
out here at the top--
that was the first
column of A. So now it's
the first row of A transpose.
This was the second
column of A. Now
it becomes the second row
of A transpose, and so on.
So that's what that
relationship is.
So I can write the parity
relationships in the form H
times C equals a
whole bunch of 0's.
This is k parody relationships.
This is k 0's here.
But I could read write the
same thing turned on its side,
and that's what you're
seeing over here.
So if H is the matrix
there, what is H transpose?
Let's see.
I'm going to change--
interchange rows and columns.
So what's going to happen
is that the first row of H
is going to become the
first column of H transpose.
And so if you imagine how
this gets turned on its side,
here's what H
transpose looks like.
H transpose looks like that.
So when you transpose a matrix
whose entries are blocks,
you end up flipping
the matrix around,
but also transposing
each of the blocks.
So that's A transpose.
Oh, actually, sorry.
I wrote this one
wrong, didn't I?
What is our vector C?
C is this vector.
It's a code word.
When I set this up in matrix
form, I got a column vector,
so I've got to
transpose this as well.
That's what I was missing.
That's C transpose
that I'm looking at.
So when I write down the
parity relationships,
I've got this, but I could
also write it in the form--
when you transpose a product
of things, what do you get?
Well, it turns out, if I
transpose the product of two
things, I get the product
of the transposes,
but in the reverse order.
So these are just different
ways of arranging the equations.
So I could have
written it in this form
or I could take the
transpose of both sides,
and I get something that
looks slightly different.
So here, this would
be a row of 0's.
So this is just to get you
comfortable with the matrix
operations.
You'll see lots of
this in chapter 6.
You want to get a little
comfortable with that.
Here's a question for you.
Here's my H matrix.
Here's my code words.
If I have a code word
of minimum weight,
how many 1's would
it have in it?
In this particular case,
this is a 9, 4, 4 code.
If I had a code word
of minimum weight,
how many 1's would
it have in it?
I heard something,
but I didn't hear
where it came from, or
didn't hear it very clearly.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: 4--
GEORGE VERGHESE: 4?
Yeah, OK.
[INAUDIBLE] heard there.
OK.
So the code word
of minimum weight
would have weight 4, because
this is a code of distance 4.
It's a linear code.
The minimum Hamming
distance is 4.
It's a linear code, so we
know, for a linear code,
the minimum weight you'll find
among all code words is 4.
OK, so we've got a vector
here that has four 1's in it,
and everything else is 0.
So when I take this
computation, what
is it that I'm actually doing?
If I take the matrix
H and I multiplied
by a vector that
has four 1's in it,
and everything else is 0,
what is it that I'm actually
doing to that matrix?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
GEORGE VERGHESE: Of the rows?
Am I taking combination
of the rows?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
GEORGE VERGHESE: When
I do a multiplication
in this fashion with the
vector on the right-hand side,
I end up doing the opposite
of what I was doing here.
When I have the vector on
the left and I multiply,
I'm taking the
combinations of the rows.
When I've matrix
times vector, I'm
taking combination
of the columns.
So if I had a vector
year with four 1's in it,
and everything's 0--
everything else
0, I'd be taking--
I'd be picking out four
columns of this to add,
and the result
would be a 0 vector.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
all 0 [INAUDIBLE]
GEORGE VERGHESE: All 0's here?
AUDIENCE: All 0's
for your code--
GEORGE VERGHESE:
Were you asking,
why all 0's for the code?
AUDIENCE: Well, why
you can't have all 0's?
GEORGE VERGHESE:
You can have all 0.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
GEORGE VERGHESE: Sorry.
The minimum weight non-zero
vector is the Hamming distance.
Sorry.
I may have dropped that word.
For a linear code, we know that
the minimum Hamming distance
is the minimum weight
non-zero vector.
That's what I meant to say.
I may have neglected
to say that.
Thanks for catching that.
So we have a
non-zero vector here.
It's got four 1's in it.
What that tells us is that there
are four columns here that we
can add together and
get the 0 vector.
Do you think it's going to
be possible to find three
columns here that we could add
together and get the 0 vector?
I'm not asking
you to actually do
the computation in
your head, but based
on the reasoning we just had,
if you found three columns that
could be added together to
give you the 0 vector, that
would mean you'd have a vector
here, a code word with--
or any vector here
with three ones in it,
everything else 0, such
that this product was 0.
So it would be a
valid code word.
Is that possible to take a
vector here with just three 1's
in it, everything else 0,
and have a valid code word?
No, right?
We said the minimum
Hamming distance is 4,
the minimum weight
code word here is--
has got weight 4.
You'll not find a valid
code word of weight 3.
So you can actually
look at this H matrix
and figure out what the
minimum Hamming distance is.
It's basically the
minimum number of columns
that you can add to
get the 0 vector.
Now, does that tell
you, by the way, why you
can't, in this instance, have--
well, if you discovered
that you could
add two columns together
and get the 0 vector,
what would that tell you?
If two columns of A transpose
were identical or two rows of A
were identical,
that would tell you
that you can add two columns
and get the 0 vector.
That would mean that the Hamming
distance is 2, not 4, right?
A Hamming distance 2
code is not worth much.
It's no good for
error correction.
That comes back to what I said
earlier in these questions.
If A had two rows the
same, well, there's
two data bits that
are always entering
in the same combination,
so you're not
protecting against
individual errors there.
And so it's exactly that
issue that we're seeing.
The Hamming distance
ends up being
2, if you have two rows
of A that are identical.
OK, so there's a lot
that can be gleaned
from the generator matrix
and the parity check matrix.
So this is what I
just went through--
that, if you have
the H matrix, you
can get the minimum
distance D by looking
to see what's the minimum
number of columns you
can add to get the 0 vector.
All right, now, how
does decoding work?
We've gone through this effort
to generate a code word,
and then, at the receiving
end, we get some word.
This is some received
word, and it's
going to be a code word
plus possibly an error.
And now we want
to figure out, is
the thing we received
already a code word?
Or if it's not, what code
word can I correct it to?
And we're going to assume we
have just single-bit errors.
So one way to do it is just
an exhaustive search, which
is you've got this
received code word,
you know that it's going
to be one of 2 to the k--
so it's going to be no more than
having distance 1 from the 2
to the k code words that
you have in your code set.
So you can compare against
those 2 to the k code words,
and whichever one it's
having distance 1 away from,
that's the one that
you're going to announce.
So that'd be one way to do it.
The thing is that that's
not exploiting anything
nice about the structure
of linear code,
so what I want to
talk to you about now
is a way to actually
capture this error
in the case of a linear code.
So this builds on
the relationships
that we've been developing
some intuition for here.
So here's what happens.
You get a received
vector and bits,
which is valid code word
plus a vector E that
has a single 1 in it,
and everything else 0,
or is completely 0.
So if you were receiving
the code word correctly,
you've had no errors,
and this is what you get.
But if you've had
a single bit error,
then E is a vector
with a single 1 in it.
It's n bits long, has
a single one in it,
and that gets added
to the code word
to give you what you receive.
So here's what
we're going to do.
We're going to exploit
the relationships
that we had up here.
We know that H times is a
valid code word equals 0.
Or I can write it the other
way around if I want to do row
multiplications-- sorry--
C times H equals 0.
So I'm going to take
the receipt vector
and do that
multiplication with it.
And in this case, I've
chosen to write it
as H times the transpose.
So if the received vector
was a valid code word,
I'm going to get 0.
If the received vector
was not a valid code word,
I'll get something else.
And that's what we refer
to as a syndrome vector.
OK, so let's expand this out.
We've got R is C plus E--
so C plus E transpose.
That's the multiplication
we're going to do.
This matrix
multiplication will be
the sum of the individual
matrix multiplications,
so it's going to be
H times C plus H--
sorry-- H times C transpose
plus H times E transpose.
So let's write that out.
So we've got H
times R transpose is
going to be H times C transpose
plus H times E transpose.
We know this is 0.
It's a 0 vector.
n minus k here, the number
of parity relations--
that's how long
that 0 vector is.
Yeah.
And then we've got
some other vector,
which we're referring
to as a syndrome vector.
OK?
So let's see.
What does HE
transpose look like.
E transpose is going to
have just a single 1 in it
somewhere.
And here's H. Let's see.
A transpose stacked up next
to the identity-- that's
what H looked like.
So when we compute--
let me write this better--
I didn't write that well--
this is H.
And what I'm writing
here is HE transpose.
So what is HE transpose doing?
When I multiply a
matrix like this
by a vector that has
just a single 1 in it,
what am I doing?
What do I end up doing?
Sorry.
I heard a voice
from somewhere here.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
GEORGE VERGHESE: Picking
up one column, right?
I'm just selecting
out a column of H.
So each error that you
can get will give you
a syndrome that corresponds
to picking on one column of H.
And column of H is
associated with data bits
here or parity bits here.
So really, this is
all that you have
to do to do your
error correction.
You can pre-compute, or store
basically the columns of H
in your database--
compute H times the received
vector to get the syndrome.
That's really H times
the error, which
is giving you the syndrome.
That's just a single column
of H. So the syndromes
that you can possibly get
are individual columns of H.
So you know what H is.
You've got it stored.
Compute the syndrome,
and see which column of H
it corresponds to.
That's the bit
that has the error.
And actually, the only
cases you're interested in
are where you are going
to correct the data bit,
so this is really all
the part that you really
have to focus on.
So you compute the syndromes.
You compare against the columns
of H, which are your syndrome
vectors, and then you're done.
I think I see the
same thing over here.
Let's just look
at it concretely--
again, for the same code,
the rectangular code
with all the parity bits there.
So this is how you
generated a code word.
Sorry.
OK, let's take the data bit--
the data vector being all 1's.
This is the code word
that goes with it.
It happens with
this particular code
that all the parity
bits then are 0.
What you receive ends up being
this, because one of the data
bits ends up getting corrupted.
When you take that received
vector and pre-multiplied by H,
here's the resulting
syndrome vector that you get.
And what error does
on correspond to?
Well, actually, if you
look in the columns of H,
you'll see that what
you've pulled out
is the second
column, so that means
a second data bit is an error.
And that's the
change that you make.
So it really is that simple.
You take the received
word pre-multiplied
by the parity check matrix H,
look at the syndrome vector,
and see which of the columns
of H that corresponds to.
That's the bit
you're going to flip.
All right?
So now you're actually only
dealing with this many vectors.
It's a number of
vectors equal to--
how many is that?
We've got to do
the multiplication,
but you just have to compare
with the number of vectors
in those columns.
So it's a much simpler
task, computationally.
OK, I think we've said all this.
And so let me just
wind up on linear block
codes with a quick
summary, and then we'll
go on to talk about
some extensions here.
We've seen all this.
We know what the rate of a
linear code is-- k over n--
how many errors we can correct.
And we've seen all this--
what a parity bit does,
whether repetition code--
it's called replication
code in the notes, but the
more familiar term-- actually,
the more commonly used
term is repetition code.
We've looked at Hamming codes
and the rectangular code
as well.
And so these are
the ones that you
want to have in mind
as particular examples
to work with when you're trying
to come up with examples that
will either prove or disprove--
that will illustrate
a conjecture
or disprove a
conjecture, for instance.
And you'll see many
problems on past quizzes
that are of that type.
And then what we did today was
looking at syndrome decoding.
All right, so this was all
focused on single error
correction in linear codes.
But the point is that
that may or may not
be the situation that
you're dealing with.
We actually said that, to
get better error protection
while maintaining
high data rates,
you probably want to work
with longer and longer strings
of data.
Well, if you work with
longer strings of data,
you're going to get
more bits and error.
So you may not be
able to limit yourself
to thinking about
single-bit error correction.
We have talked a bit--
and you've done this in
recitation too, I imagine--
well, you've probably done more
in recitation than in lecture--
with independent corruption
of multiple bits.
So let me say a few
words about that.
Let's think of a
systematic code,
for instance, still k bits
here, and then parity bits here.
But what if you could have
up to t errors, not just
a single error--
so if you wanted to
protect against t errors?
So in some sense, you
want your n minus k bits
here to signal all
those possibilities,
so you need the number
of possibilities
that can be signaled by
n minus k parity bits
to be greater than or
equal to the number
of possible conditions
that correspond
to having up to t errors.
And we've said a
little bit about this,
but you can have now either
no error at all, which
is one condition; or an error
in one of these bits, which
is n separate conditions;
or you could have two bits
out of here being an error.
So how many conditions is that?
n choose 2 and so on--
I'll leave you to figure out
where you end up on that.
So I just wanted to say--
you've seen this in recitation,
but I haven't mentioned it
in lecture.
I don't want to say
later that, oh, I
didn't know it was something
we had to know for a quiz.
We do expect that
what n choose m means.
So n choose m is
the number of ways
of picking m things
from n things,
and we assume that what that--
how that's done.
So you've got n objects.
You want to pick m
things from there.
So you can pick the first one
in n ways, the second one in n
minus 1 ways, and keep
on going until you
get to n minus n plus 1, which
is also n factorial over n
minus m factorial.
But when you did
that picking, you
were paying attention to the
order in which you collected
the things, but if the ordering
doesn't matter to you--
if all these objects
are interchangeable--
then you've actually
overcounted.
So you've got m things,
but the order in which you
pick them doesn't matter,
because they're all
interchangeable.
And so you've overcounted.
You've got to divide by the
number of ways of rearranging m
things, and so that's how
you get that expression.
So you start off with thinking
about how you pick m things,
and then make a
little correction,
and so this is
what n choose m is.
Another thing that I
just threw in for fun,
because it's something
you might want
to carry around in your head--
if you don't have a feel for
how n factorial grows with n,
well, it actually
grows pretty fast.
It's actually growing
like n to the n.
This is a very famous
approximation, referred to
as Sterling's approximation.
So when you get out to
large n, the right-hand side
here is a very good
approximation to n factorial.
And you see that it's sort
of like n to the n, which
makes sense, because you
seem to be multiplying n
by itself n times.
Except you're multiplying
by a little bit less than n
each time, so the e over there
ends up compensating for it,
it turns out.
And then there's an extra
n to the 1/2 out there.
OK, so we'll assume that
how to do the combinatorics.
And now, what this
is saying is, what's
the probability
of getting m bits
and error in an n-bit word?
Well, if you've got
m bits in error,
that's because those m
bits flipped independently,
each with probability p.
The remaining n
minus m did not flip,
so that's the probability of
getting one such configuration.
And then you count all the
possible configurations.
So what that top expression is
is the probability of getting
m bits in error out
of n, and that's
something that we want you
to be comfortable with.
OK, now, just to
wind up here, I want
to go back to this
last bullet, which
is that, in many
situations, the errors don't
occur independently
in the different bits.
If you think of a CD with
a scratch or a thumb print
or something on
it, that's local,
and so if you get
one bit corrupted,
that increases the
chances that the next bit
is corrupted as well.
So errors can occur in bursts.
If you're trying to make
a phone call from a car,
and you're suddenly
shielded from an antenna--
a nearby antenna,
then you're going
to lose a whole bunch
of bits in sequence.
So bits can be in
error in clusters,
and what we've talked about so
far doesn't quite manage that.
So here's an idea for
how to do that, which
is referred to as interleaving.
So if we had B
different code words
that we were going to transmit,
and we did it the normal way,
we would send out the first
one, second one, and so on.
This little shading
here is supposed
to indicate the parity bits
going along with the data bits.
If we had a burst of errors,
we could lose two entire words
over there--
nothing to be done.
They derive entirely corrupted,
and we wouldn't get them back.
The idea of interleaving
is stack up B words
that you want to
transmit, but transmit
the bits out one at a time
from each of the B words.
So you transmit the first
bit from the first word,
first bit from the
second word, and so on.
And so this is the
sequence in which
you're doing the transmission.
Now, if you've got
a burst of errors,
you're corrupting a
more localized set
of bits in each of the
words, and there's some hope
that your error correction
then can recover.
So this is very often done.
I don't think I want
to actually walk you
through a particular
scheme for it,
but we'll have it on the
slides for you to look through.
But basically, it actually
turns out to work very well.
And that may be all I
want to do for today.
We'll see you next time.
We're going to talk about
linear codes next time,
but a much more
elaborate kind of code
called a convolutional code.
Thank you.